welcome to this video playing ah stunts
stunts 3 3 ok I'm going with this kind
of symmetrical set up a prayer that
that's already rather comfortable
variation there ok what now hmm c6
keeping that center maybe let's try to
keep that center you shouldn't be bad
really having that pond center with
black
prepare you should be 60 k wants to play
a 5 it seems so I'm sorry has bacon for
Freudian slip before so I go fi okay
yeah one day FP five is a move maybe
let's do this simply stop all things
there any b4 b5 business ok now you can
try to abuse at c 5 squared it's a kind
of not really related to the rest of his
position so i won't learn how good it
really is rook c8 and maybe
okay let's let's check that porn on
before and now i have e for i was
thinking let's do that I just gain space
it's a bit loose my position is a bit
loose but still it's it's lots of space
okay
yes 95 but I go to f7 and then 94 is an
issue I'm really playing on that on that
space advantage so night a 44 93 it's
bishop on g2 and I don't even wanna they
are really rather sorry looking pieces
that's the idea okay um just back to f7
now let's do it
but what am I going to do next maybe
Knight c3 Brooke be 2nite deform just
double attacking each one that could be
a good idea yeah okay that was of course
possible but I thought that the a porn
must be something I mean relief with the
bishop on g7 how to believe that this
shouldn't be good for for me so let's
see if i move the night is this night is
attacked i can probably win the D porn
him
default Bishop b3 is also pretty pretty
interesting but at it it's not them it's
not so not so clear okay I'm just trying
to win that pawn made it I don't know
I'm really unsure about it 94 this be
porn gets gets really active and I
cannot know it's not doing that I really
didn't see that move Wow
93 Bishop f8 it is interesting but I'm
losing control a little bit him and
played that badly my position was was
clearly better but this is some this is
not not clear at all now
now I hope the pond are strong enough to
secure draw but luxury one I think you
can take you five actually didn't
Group D for Bishop c5 and then I'll take
on e3 plane I'd see too well that works
why really completely lost control over
that position it was really nice
I with maybe I'm still okay yeah the
time war didn't see them but you know
then he takes it down so I have to take
this song check I mean that a point is
rather rather strong 47 seconds how is
he how is he stopping that pawn it's not
okay white resign I was very lucky I was
really lucky completely completely lost
control over that position which I think
was pretty good here so somewhere around
here I think it should be really good
for me but I didn't play it well this is
this here so what what is a default
better okay much better really and now
this year I thought you can take here
alright this is a strong move okay this
is a stronger and the team black's
pieces are super active this this is
actually a better foot black still I
have a clear advantage according to the
engine so I didn't really spoil it wow
wow it is very is actually good for
black hair d 4 immediately was even
strong
ooh could be for a three and black wins
with the airport I didn't I didn't I
really thought I had Ted spoiled it
somehow because I thought there should
be something from here there is
something he can take on d5 yeah I saw
that he can take it but when I wasn't
sure something like this the engine says
equal so maybe I'm still still okay here
the computer should be if it says 000
that that is that is certainly certainly
okay with what line however what is it
giving OPC one aha check and this
hmm said really ok this is this idea
yeah okay it's probably really a drawn
okay and after this d4 and winning s
yeah I'm winning amazing I Bishop g7 was
even simpler this is jesse's does work
Emma I'm just promoting that porn ok so
I actually didn't spoil it it really
looked like it at least it felt kind of
unnecessarily messy which is probably
the right way right way to call it ok
well thanks for watching